One of the most amazing things about
the parallel growth of data science
and genetics has been the growth
of data. The human genome has about
40,000 genes and that in turn is made
up of about three million base pairs.
The first human genome was sequenced in
2001 and took several years to complete.
But in recent years, researchers have sequenced
thousands of genome and it’s becoming relatively
simple task for a lab to do this nowadays.
What this means is that, genetic data is now
produced much faster than it can be organized
or analyzed or interpreted or implemented. Part
of this is that the methods for structuring data,
that is, having a shared way of putting it
together and making it easy to transport
between labs and between researchers, as well
as methods of communicating the findings lag
dramatically behind the development of the ability
to get data. Data’s a good thing, but you have to
be able to make sense of it. Indeed, we’ve a
lot of data that is potentially of great use.
There’s a lot of untapped potential. Let’s
discuss about a few of the things that had been
particularly successful in using genetics
and the data science of healthcare.
Number one is predicting disease risks
through genetics. When most people
think of genetics and disease, they think of
single gene causes like the gene for cancer.
But things are rarely so simple. Most diseases
involve what are called polygenic interactions,
or the combined effect of many genes,
possibly thousands all at once.
The enormous increase in the amount of data
available, along with the development of data
science have made it possible to detect many of
these polygenic effects. So, they can actually now
say, this combination, for instance, of 400 genes
collectively work to predict a particular disease.
There’s a unique study on Parkinson’s disease,
conducted as part of the Parkinson’s progression
markers initiative, that made it possible for
researchers to combine data from genetics,
from imaging, from clinical data, and from
demographics data to altogether develop a
highly accurate model for predicting a
patient’s risk of Parkinson’s disease.
Similarly, researchers at other institutions have
also made progress on mining DNA data to predict
diseases ranging from coronary artery disease to
breast cancer to diabetes and a host of others.
But it’s important to remember that DNA is not
destiny. Even in identical twins who share the
same DNA, diseases do not show up the same.
Really, what data science do is they give
probabilities but not a concrete this is the
way it is. And that’s important to remember
because not only are there test for things
like certain kinds of cancer or Parkinson’s,
but also researchers have been developing
test for things like IQ and mental illness.
Some of which, because they’re based on DNA, can
be administered while the embryo is still in the
womb. And this raises a huge number of ethical
dilemmas. We’ll talk about some of these later,
but it recalls the movie Gattaca where people
were categorized and really channeled according
to their genetic potential. It’s important to
remember that in something like identical twins,
who again, have 100% the same DNA, things like
schizophrenia, major mental illness, only 50%
concordance. What that means is if one twin
has developed schizophrenia, there’s only a 50%
chance, a flip of a coin, that the other one has
it as well. So, it’s important to be a little
humble, a little circumspect when interpreting the
probabilities that come from predictive analytics
for diseases through DNA. And there’s also, a
need to focus on controllable factors, especially
when you look at things like heart disease.
There’s so many things that a person can do,
like diet and exercise, that can help reduce the
person’s risk, even if it never changes their DNA.
But keeping that all in mind,
the ability to gather huge amounts of genetic
data and the mechanisms that are making it
easier to sort through potentially trillions
of data points, to try to find an association
with the disease are bringing exciting
potential for finding and diagnosing
diseases and understanding their nature through
the combination of genetics and data science.